WE ARE DELIGHTED TO SEE YOU
TOMORROW WITH US.
EXCEPT ME, I WILL BE IN
D.C.
>> Bret: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, AND THERE APPEARS TO BE A
MAJOR SETBACK IN WHAT HAS BEEN
WIDELY PERCEIVED AS PROGRESS
TOWARDS PEACE AND OF THE
ELIMINATION
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS
ON THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
NORTH KOREA IS THREATENING TO
CANCEL NEXT MONTH'S SUMMIT
BETWEEN KIM JONG UN AND A
PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER MILITARY
DRILLS GOING ON RIGHT NOW,
INVOLVING THE U.S. AND
SOUTH KOREA.
>> THIS NEWS WAS REPORTED BY THE
SOUTH KOREAN NEWS AGENCY EARLY
WEDNESDAY MORNING.
IT COULD VERY WELL BE A WAKE-UP
CALL TO SOME WHO THOUGHT THAT
THINGS HAD COMPLETELY CHANGED
BETWEEN PYANGYOUNG AND
WASHINGTON.
>> SIGNS OF TURBULENCE IN A
REASONABLY SMOOTH RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN PYANGYOUNG AND THE U.S.
COUNSELING A MEETING BETWEEN THE
NORTH AND SOUTH KOREAN OFFICIALS
NORTH AND SOUTH KOREAN OFFICIAL
OFFICIALS.
NORTH KOREAN STATE MEDIA GOING
ON TO SAY THE UNITED STATES WILL
ALSO HAVE TO UNDERTAKE CAREFUL
DELIBERATIONS ABOUT THE FATE OF
THE U.S. SUMMIT IN LIGHT OF THIS
PROVOCATIVE MILITARY RUCKUS
JOINTLY CONDUCTED WITH THE
SOUTH KOREAN AUTHORITIES.
THE DRILLS ARE NOT PROVOCATIVE.
>> KIM JONG UN HAS SAID HE
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPORTANCE TO
THE UNITED STATES THAT WE
CONDUCT THESE JOINT EXERCISES,
AND THAT THEY CONTINUE TO GO ON.
>> AS FOR THE SUMMIT PLAN FOR
SINGAPORE IN JUNE, WASHINGTON IS
GOING FORWARD WITH PLANNING.
SOME, HOWEVER WERE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT KIM JONG UN'S RECENT
WORDS.
>> I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD TRUST
HIM, ON THE OTHER HAND I THINK
IT'S GOOD WE HAVE A DIRECT
DIALOGUE.
AND I THINK THERE ARE SOME
POSITIVE SIGNS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
RECENTLY THAT THE SUMMIT COULD
BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> Reporter: NORTH KOREA IS
GOING AHEAD WITH DISMANTLING ITS
NUCLEAR TEST SITE AND IS SHUT
SET TO BE SHUT DOWN NEXT WEEK.
>> THERE WILL CERTAINLY BE
PRIORITIZATION IN THE FIRST
INSTANCE ON DENUCLEARIZATION,
BECAUSE THAT'S THE GOAL THAT WE
SET.
>> Reporter: STILL SOME WAY
THAT EVEN IF THEY DO SIT SHOW UP
AT THE SUMMIT, THEY ONLY OFFER
PHASED DISARMAMENT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> WHEN KIM JONG UN SEES
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN SINGAPORE, HE
SHOULD GIVE SOMETHING BIG TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Bret: A STATEMENT THE
WHITE HOUSE REALLY IS JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO SAID, WE ARE
AWARE OF THE SOUTH KOREAN MEDIA
REPORT.
THE UNITED STATES WILL LOOK AT
WHAT NORTH KOREA HAS SAID